[Musica]
fate mai caso alle cose che ti accoglie
te la terra che so questa mattina ad
esempio cosa avete raccolto la terra
magari lo zaino la borsa
lo smartphone sperando che non si è
rotto il vetro
se invece vi chiedessi di pensare a cosa
raccogliete la terra ogni giorno al
lavoro probabilmente avreste un po di
difficoltà ha ricordato e molto
probabilmente dimentichereste proprio la
cosa più importante quella che
raccogliete da terra ogni giorno
e chissà da quanto tempo intanto dovete
sapere che quando gli organizzatori mi
hanno guidato questo evento
io sono andato un po in panico perché la
parola terra da un po di giorni a questa
parte
sarà l'effetto greta probabilmente mi
ricorda tutto quello che è la tutela
dell'ambiente e diciamo che non sono
propriamente i miei temi
poi qualche sera fa a pasqua durante uno
di quei momenti di malinconia che credo
sia capitato anche a voi però voi ora
non ci pensa te concentratevi sulla mia
malinconia
insomma a pasqua è arrivata all
illuminazione aisam scafate mi diceva
mio padre quando ero piccolo
usiamo questo caffè da terra allora ho
capito che in quel momento
qui oggi insieme a voi avrei voluto
capire appunto quello che noi ogni
giorno vediamo da terra e dove ci può
portare
io quando ero piccolo seguivo spesso mio
padre al lavoro quando
fanno sentire la parola
[Applauso]
quando sentite la frase preparare il
caffè probabilmente pensare ai gesti più
comuni ossia quello della macchina moka
sul fuoco oppure quello del barista sul
banco bar
ecco per me preparare il caffè ha sempre
avuto tutt'altro significato era quello
che faceva mio padre quando andava al
lavoro e io l'ho seguito spesso mio
padre entra mentore fazione caricava un
bidone pieno di caffè che faceva
scendere dai silos si piegava sulle
ginocchia la portava sulla spalla e si
dirigeva verso la pesa tritsch e che era
la bilancia elettronica riversava tutto
dentro a questa enorme macchina di ferro
a forma di imbuto poi prendeva una busta
come questa infilava tutto il braccio
dentro apriva una mano per formare la
base è la riposava sulla bilancia
premeva un pedale che era in terra che a
me sembrava quello delle vecchie
macchine tutti tutti come diciamo a
napoli c'è un lato scontro delle
giostrine per intenderci è lì per 6 7
secondi scendeva in caffè nella busta
facendo rumore che sembrava quello della
grandine sui tetti di lamiera poi
riprendeva la bussola rigosamente era
insieme fino alle altre e ricominciava
aveva un ritmo perfetto nello pace e
ostacoli che lo guardavo lo ammiravo e
gli girano intorno girando girando che
arrivano tutti i caffè ecco non
succedeva perché ero distratto anzi ero
concentratissimo succedeva probabilmente
perché non avevo ancora dimestichezza
con gli spazi in cui mi muovevo e con i
tempi in cui mi muovevo poi guardavano
mio padre egli diceva non ti preoccupare
rialzo io e papà me li faceva
raccogliere uno ad uno quei chili caffè
spazio e tempo
ricordate ecco
questi 9000 chicchi di caffè per me oggi
non sono importanti in quanto tale in
quanto caffè sono importanti perché col
tempo ho capito che avrei dovuto
imparare a misurarli avrebbe dovuto
imparare a guardare oltre con una
prospettiva internazionale non locale
volevo che il nostro mercato diventasse
glocale altrimenti questi 9000 chicchi
di caffè sarebbero rimasti lì a melito
a proposito si sente l'accento chiesa da
santini si deve sentire perché si è
sviluppato lì in quella periferia nord
di napoli dove già oggi è complicato
fare impresa quando era adolescente io
era ancora più difficile ricordo che
sento parlare il mio padre e mio
fratello della possibilità di cessione
dei marchi e dei macchinari
poi probabilmente siamo stati bravi a
capire quali fossero i nostri limiti
all'epoca a cercare di cambiare allora
abbiamo iniziato a guardare questi
chicchi di caffè sotto un'altra ottica
gli abbiamo dato probabilmente un altro
peso molto saprete quando pesa un chicco
di caffè volete provare secondo quanto
peso
questa 0,1 g la decima parte di un gran
leggerino invece sapete quand'è che
inizia a diventare pesante quando
iniziamo a guardarlo come un vaso
ecco nel momento in cui noi riusciamo a
capire il valore dei dati cambia tutto
gli spazi dove lavoriamo diventano dati
i tempi con cui ci muoviamo diventano
dati e si incrociano possiamo
incrociarli con altri dati che derivano
da fuori dai mercati
e se stiamo bene poi se siamo bravi ad
analizzarli
questi dati riusciamo a crescere perché
riusciamo a capire dove dobbiamo andare
ecco io ho iniziato a capire il valore
dei dati raccogliendo di da terra così
come mi faceva fare mio padre con i
chicchi di caffè noi abbiamo dati
ovunque voi avete dato comunque però
talvolta a causa della nostra ignoranza
della distrazione non li usiamo ed è un
peccato enorme perché poi ci chiediamo
perché le nostre aziende rischiano
all'implosione
erano gli anni quando l'ho capito dello
sviluppo dei marketplace e dei social
network in italia
a me piaceva sperimentare e studiare più
studiavo più sperimentale da un lato
avevamo il commercio che stava
diventando elettronico dall'altro le
persone che stavano iniziando a popolare
social avete presente il vecchio e
tradizionale passaparola il mercatino
rionale uguale semplicemente quelle
dinamiche stavano iniziando a diventare
digitali e io dovevo capirlo ed essere
bravo ad incastrare le due cose
dovevo iniziare a comunitaria così però
non volevo farlo con le classiche
tradizionali pubblicità costosissime e
allora ho fatto universo ho aperto la
porta della torrefazione
a 7 miliardi di potenziali clienti ho
iniziato a comunicare quello che per me
voleva dire preparare il caffè in quel
momento ha preso un valore assoluto
una verità assoluta la prima famosa tesi
del manifesto di coltrane ossia che i
mercati sono conversazioni abbiamo
venduto nel nostro primo box di caffè
durante la semifinale del mondiale 2006
italia germany
ecco a me piace pensare che ci sono dei
momenti che resteranno indelebili
quel gol di grosso è un momento che per
noi resterà per sempre allo stesso tempo
negli stessi anni
gli esperti di digital marketing
iniziavano a parlare di ascolto della
rete bisognava capire quello che la rete
diceva nei social dunque per provare poi
a soddisfare i suoi bisogni quelli della
rete
io mi sono sempre spinto un po oltre ho
sempre aspirato una comunicazione che
andasse oltre all'ascolto della rete
intesa come entità astratta
ho sempre voluto un dialogo con l'utente
un utente che avesse un nome un cognome
è una faccia proprio come noi non ho mai
concepito quello stupido claim che vuole
che il cliente ha sempre ragione perché
non è vero che il cliente ha sempre
ragione e comunque tutte le volte che ha
ragione anche il cliente può essere
comprensivo ed empatico verso il brand
così come brand deve essere empatico e
comprensivo verso il cliente
[Applauso]
ed è questo concetto importantissimo
perché ogni volta che noi lasciamo una
lamentela online verso un'azienda questo
è andato ed è un dato negativo che si
ripercuoterà prima sulla reputazione del
brand e poi sul fatturato di riflesso e
quindi non li facciamo crescere su
questa visione anzi microclima e per
fare questo occorre creare un rapporto
di sintonia e fiducia con i clienti
però l'importante non è soltanto crearlo
l'importante poi è tenerlo nel tempo
persona per persona cliente per cliente
in questo modo il brand può anche
fungere da educatore nei confronti del
cliente non soltanto sui suoi prodotti
ma anche sul sistema lavoro in generale
su come si vive in altri canali di
mercato ad esempio online su questa
visione qualche tempo fa qualche anno fa
un noto direttore marketing di una
grossa multinazionale italiana mi ha
detto è tu parli così perché non ti
rendi conto perché gestisce una piccola
azienda
no io parlo così perché sono fermamente
convinto che il rapporto umano sia forse
l'unico elemento che l'azienda non debba
mai essere automatizzato più cresceranno
i numeri dei nostri clienti
più saremo noi in grado di gestirli uno
ad uno e più i brand avranno successo
io credo che la compravendita sia una
cosa semplicissima è uno scambio tra
persone da un lato ci sono persone che
prodotti li preparano e li vendono
dall'altro ci sono persone che li
acquistano e li consumano si tratta di
scambi commerciali e commercio è fatto
di persone
il commercio è una parte della società e
le persone sono persone fisiche persone
giuridiche e noi dobbiamo capire tutti
che anche le persone giuridiche cioè le
aziende sono fatte da persone come noi
che un giorno abbiamo un ruolo quello
del cliente l'altro abbiamo un altro
ruolo quello del fornitore
per farlo però ovviamente per instaurare
questo tipo di rapporto dobbiamo noi
essere per primi consapevoli dei nostri
limiti perché siamo artigiani ed in
quanto artigiani non saremo mai in
effetti lo dobbiamo sapere lo dobbiamo
ammettere altrimenti non saremo mai
credibili agli occhi di quei clienti a
cui magari domani dobbiamo chiedere
comprensione per un nostro eventuale
errore però attenzione e sul concetto di
artigianato
voglio essere chiaro io non sono per il
concetto di piccolo è bello
dobbiamo imparare a risolvere i problemi
dobbiamo imparare a crescere quindi
dobbiamo iniziare a valorizzarla si
l'artigianalità e tutto il comparto
artigianale
però dobbiamo capire come dobbiamo
crescere
vedete mio padre sempre anche negli
ultimi tempi in cui alimento relazione
che non stava bene capitava che
rispondesse al telefono quando si
trattava di un cliente che chiedeva
informazioni sul prodotto lui
tranquillamente riusciva a risolvere
tutto quando invece si trattava di una
richiesta l'informazione magari su una
spedizione non consegnata in tempo
ecco allora che mio padre segnava tutto
e quando io tornavo mi dava quel
bigliettino con su scritto indovinare
che cosa i dati tutti i dati di questi
gente e mi diceva ha chiamato tizio dice
che un problema con la spedizione mi
raccomando chiama la cappa re brutto
controlla e chiamano che pare brutto
quindi rigoroso lavora verifica e
risolve il problema al cliente che
sembra brutto allora il rispetto verso
quel cliente perché ci ha scelto e se
non lo richiami non si sceglierà più
semplice controlla e chiamano in questa
frase c'è tutto vede io credo che mio
padre quando ero piccolo lasciandomi
raccogliere quei chicchi di caffè ad uno
ad uno mi ha insegnato la cosa più
importante
il valore del tempo l'interpretazione
dei dati e il rispetto per le persone
grazie
[Applauso]